there will be a subsect of people who
very much feel that it was a necessary
evil potentially to get the message out
sometimes when I think about the whole
picture it's just mind-blowing this is
even a thing seems like a like a movie
almost it's just absurd
Derek welcome to the show thanks for
having me dude you broke the internet
this week man what the [ __ ] no wild yeah
absolutely wild has there ever been this
much attention on you do you think
um I don't know to be honest
um I I feel like the thing is so much
bigger than me at this point that I
don't even know if it's necessarily
attention on me or just the situation at
large that's a really really good point
yeah so it's it's tough to say but
probably not maybe when I went on Rogan
last year I think it got a decent amount
of attention but I don't know how long
have you been working on this
um as far as like the actual editing and
putting together you know the script and
whatnot
um I think in totality it was like a
month probably
yeah that's a big project yeah
[ __ ] especially for a guy who usually
just films off the cuff and just talks
you know whatever comes to mind kind of
thing yes so
you've put this hour-long documentary
out that is talking about emails that
you've received explaining what the
liver King was taking in terms of his
steroid cycle in terms of some bits of
blood work and health markers and all
the rest of it that you've done from
that
obviously you've been with this content
for a long time
and then you release it into the world
you know how you reacted to it and then
you're going to make predictions about
how the Public's going to react what are
your thoughts on the reaction to
this information so far
um I think it has been
pretty
it went more viral than I was expecting
but the overall response I feel was
pretty aligned with what I was expecting
in terms of there was going to be a
subset of people who no matter what
happens they were still you know
hardcore supporters of the guy
regardless and certain individuals who
kind of knew what was going to happen at
some point anyways and had a feeling
that this kind of information was going
to come out and like very much me as
well like even before this stuff came to
light I was like somebody [ __ ] has
this for sure like he's definitely put
this out there in in some context to
somebody and like as he gets I don't
know gains more notoriety like
somebody's going to feel I don't know
obliged to put out the truth I would
imagine so I don't know just felt like a
matter of time and I think the the
general response was fairly expected
just far more viral than I ever
anticipated well that's riding off the
back of his virality right you know he's
been one of the biggest guests on pretty
much every big podcast over the last
year or so the Logan Paul calls the
h3h3s ETC he's been everywhere and on
that vehemently denied like absolutely
denied what is it that he says Peds are
prioritize execute and determinism or
something uh dominant some anyway uh
just outright Stonewall I haven't taken
I don't need these you can achieve this
body if you follow these nine ancestral
tenants and I think that
there's some
sense of like um Vindication that people
have when a hypocrisy gets called out
like that and I think that's one of the
big reasons you've got all of this all
of these waves of exposure and then pink
there's undeniable proof yeah it's uh
hopefully it doesn't lead to a skewing
like the thing I worry about is there
are individuals who are genetic
anomalies who do work their asses off
and are actually natural and typically
when something like this like it's not
like this is an everyday thing but when
something like this happens it very much
frames the I would imagine the Layman
perspective to assume that any good
physique might then equate to hormone
use and then oh you know the the
limitations on what they think is
possible the bar drops a little bit
which I'm sure that is partially what
fueled his like mentality to justify
this whole thing is he would like
obviously he has his own you know
monetary incentive and upside out on
that and whatnot but also from one of
the points you would always make is
um the self-limiting beliefs and you
know you're putting yourself in a box
and this and that like there are
individuals who could otherwise do great
things without having to take drugs it's
not something that you need to do to
have a great physique that's
um you know going to be seen as a
top-tier
representation of health and fitness so
hopefully that message doesn't get lost
in this whole debacle oh that everybody
assumes the only way that you could get
into yeah remotely good shape would be
to take these because this guy did yeah
because I think that's like one of the
downsides of the nanny or not discussion
can kind of skew into that like
obviously having a realistic
expectations is great but at the same
time you don't want to
put yourself in a I don't know like in a
box where you think that every single
good physique out there or anything that
is representative of Elites I don't know
the physical representation of you know
Elite tier body composition is oh
definitely drugs I might as well not
even try there's two things going on
with Nadia nuts I think on one side it
is
um trying not to dissuade people who
think the only way I can achieve a good
physique is to use PDS but on the other
side is bringing down the expectations
of people who think I should be able to
look like that without Peds like this is
the uh like forever balance that I think
is being struck with like your content
or Greg's content or whoever else I
think the good thing though is guys like
uh grego Gallagher Matt does Fitness Who
come out and show like this is what I do
with lpds like a [ __ ] tank and are
willing to actually go out there and
prove that they're natural too with like
stringent testing and like if they want
to be a role model for now natural
Fitness like I think those guys
represent the you know upper echelon of
what could otherwise be achievable if
you had great genetics but also worked
your ass off eat clean Etc and um yeah
hopefully that message doesn't get lost
the most mid-wit take that I've seen
this week is living Kings on steroids
like oh my God who could have predicted
like everybody knew this I knew this
this isn't shocking information it's
like yeah that is not a smart opinion
like that's and that's the most common
critical message that I've seen online
like dude it's not about the fact that
he had a very unnatural physique and
it's now being confirmed as being
unnatural it was about how blatant and
flagrant his lies were like that's what
people are shocked by like if this guy
is able to
so naturally point blank with ease on
the biggest Platforms in the world say
I've never touched steroids and he's
self-assured in his lies like what else
has he lied about what else is this sort
of a person capable of it's like the
liar King like that's that's the
position that I think needs to be taken
no it's wild how he'll just you know
look people in the eye and just [ __ ]
flat out have his script ready to go and
say the exact same thing every single
time at what he deems to be the I don't
like the risk on that too like I just
don't understand the the perception of
the ROI when you know the information's
out there too
like The Smoking Gun was there even if
nobody else knew about it he did yeah
and like obviously even internally among
his team they knew about it and they had
put out information you think his team
knew about it they messaged me
oh on his behalf asking for you to sort
oh so it wasn't him that emailed you he
emailed me but also one of his team
members emailed me too and was like
literally subject line video content
idea or something of that nature
hey this would be a great YouTube video
Brian Johnson has this issue with you
know igf-1 he's taking four times the
dose of HGH with no success I think it
would make for great content for you to
like figure this out I'm just you know
that kind of thing was is this the email
that you missed no oh I I missed both
those emails how the [ __ ] did you miss
those emails because I have a separate
subsection for contact form requests
right and on my blog I don't really look
at it like I used to because I don't
write anymore I don't think I've written
an article in like two or three years
and they just pile up dude so and it's
like I can imagine you can relate to me
in that once you have seven inboxes and
they fill up every single day eventually
[ __ ] goes by the wayside and you will
just never you'll never see the light of
day yeah some stuff even goes into the
spam filter that might otherwise not
have made it into the priority inbox
like there's how much did you kick
yourself when you realized that you had
this dude when I saw it my it was like a
movie moment I swear it was just like
you searched for an email about this
topic whilst making the video yeah and
that email that you've never seen before
just appeared Yeah so basically I was
looking for the email that was forwarded
to me that had blood work breakdown like
the the questionnaire thing where he
broke down you know his daily routine
Etc his cycle Etc and then as I was
doing that underneath there was unread
messages from anything that had that
word in it of at
ancestralsupplements.com very few things
in my inbox that actually have that and
it was unread from May 2021 I was like
well this is old what the [ __ ] is this
and the the sender I'm just I'm I was
just like what so I opened it and I see
who it is like there's no [ __ ] way
and then I see this other email too I
was like wow I can't believe this has
been sitting here this entire time like
my impression was and I thought this was
what he was going to do and I was sort
of watching to see if this was what he
was going to do is go on all the biggest
podcasts and then at the end culminate
it with a you know what guys this is the
actual truth and I thought that it would
help push the message harder but this is
the truth and I hope you guys have to do
this ahead of your video maybe yeah he
was going to do all of these podcasts I
thought that was maybe a scenario that
might happen where he was trying to like
collect the Infinity Stones of podcasts
essentially and then end it with Rogan
and like have the gauntlet and be like
Oh I'm fake Nanny and I hope you guys
can accept it and then hopefully the
steam he's built up to there the net
outcome would still be so significant
that the people that stuck by him would
be yes I thought that was a potential
possibility but then it just never
seemed to happen but also Rogan didn't
want to have him anyways and and that
um is there any more information that
you didn't include in the video was
there anything that you felt was too
much to hold back
uh blood work I felt like it was a very
long and elaborate dissection and I felt
like it kind of just was a little bit it
wasn't like redundant because I had I
guess new information it was more for
the Nerds and the guys who were highly
interested in that stuff and
um it just didn't feel like it added
more after the first video to
put it out when I feel like the
communicated message was already
sufficient to kind of
achieve the I don't know
kind of show exactly what had happened
from inception to now I don't
necessarily think that going down the
complete scientific dismantlement of
like a blood test panel was going to be
something that added more to the
conversation other than being I don't
know highly confusing or otherwise maybe
even boring or I don't know like it just
didn't seem like it was going to add
more to that was uh worthwhile to pile
on at that point I wonder whether
there's more uh secrets about his past
his business practices drug use there's
zero chance that there's not more stuff
out there with like there's no way I was
the only person he tried to reach out to
or this other coach there's definitely
more out there for sure that's the
concern right it's the same reason why
um telling rumors about somebody to
another third party friend is always
dangerous because it's not just about
the fact that you're telling the rumors
but it's the interpretation of the third
party friend about you being the sort of
person that tells rumors right this is
the concern that no one ever really
thinks about when they start gossiping
it's like you get known as a gossip in
the same way now liver King has been the
most Brazen confident full-fledged liar
on the biggest Platforms in the world
what else does that suggest that he can
do yeah like the ambient anxiety that he
must have yeah of just whatever it is
all of the business practices are under
scrutiny now everyone's got eyes on him
um yeah it wouldn't surprise me if
there's more to come yeah yeah that's
why I was kind of surprised his apology
wasn't just a concise and full-fledged
admittance of what happened and just
that's it it had like hedges in it and
kind of side tangents that might have
been interpreted as kind of like
cop-outs a little bit what did you think
about the apology video
um I thought it was very well crafted
and I think the his supporters very much
appreciated it and a lot of them were
like we don't care [ __ ] it doesn't
matter but I do think that some of the
stuff in there that was mentioned was a
little bit of a
a little bit of a hedge to justify like
oh yeah people are have mental health
issues and are killing themselves so I
took Peds like you know to build this
more viral brand to then get my message
out to the masses further to help the
people who are suicidal but and because
I also have mental issues like he
mentions his insecurity and whatnot but
it's like is you building this character
that is unachievable naturally helping
body image issues for men 100
[ __ ] infinitely worse but essentially
he's causing the low self-esteem that he
claims he's here to support yeah and
then it's also it would be one thing if
there was no monetary upside to it but
for him to continue to hammer that my
businesses grow 50 year over year
without my without my push it's like
[ __ ] off like there's no chance his
physique was created to sell supplements
right that's why it was that it was
premeditated now his self-esteem may
play into this this you know a lot of
businesses are like a commercial
manifestation of the person right like
your businesses have a bit of Derrick in
them or a lot of Derek in them because
they're like your philosophy infuses
into them uh but yeah you can't claim
that your physique has got nothing to do
with creating a boatload of money for
yourself it's in the email yeah like
it's in the [ __ ] email there yeah and
it's like while I I do totally
understand the the benefits of trt and
you know HRT and having proper medical
oversight Etc like some of the the
justifications for like Deca and
Winstrol and stuff that is clearly only
included to enhance your image to
like in your 40s there's nothing
ancestral or conducive to longevity
about adding in Winstrol like let's be
[ __ ] honest so
um when he said it didn't help it's just
like well what was the desired outcome
of it to begin with when can you not
support people through depression
without taking a metric [ __ ] ton of gear
like is that not is that not possible
like I'm helping you not kill yourself
by taking a Winstrol oh
man well what do you think about the
apology dude
that man is like a WWE star yeah to me I
the the Cadence of the speech it was
obviously heavily prepared and maybe
even entirely scripted I think there's
one Arrow throughout the whole thing
um the whole like [ __ ] movements and
the pointing to the sky and these sort
of
um pre-prepared little routines of words
to me are not what an apology video is
supposed to be about he doesn't seem
sorry he doesn't seem sad there is no
part of vulnerability in that it seems
unbelievably performative to me and you
could say
um that is part of his personality maybe
that's just the Cadence and like the way
that he speaks and stuff I'm prepared to
accept that but
I didn't feel sympathy for him and I
feel sympathy
um other YouTubers do apologies and I'm
like yeah fair enough uh all of the
caveats when it came to
um this is to do with self-esteem the
immediate misdirection toward four
thousand men a day kill themselves and
80 000 men a day try to take their own
lives and stuff like that it's like bro
no one no one criticized you about that
no one even brought that up yeah
um
he also said it's complicated
do you think it's complicated no not
really
you took drugs like you were called out
for taking drugs and lying about it yeah
well that's the complication I would
understand the complication if he was on
therapeutic replacement and that was it
from day one and he didn't want people
to think that his therapeutic
replacement was something that everyone
needed if they were following a good
lifestyle diet Etc and there wasn't
monetary upside to what he was doing and
there wasn't this like lying to their
faces and all this stuff but it was just
yeah it was uh I don't know like the
apology was not some of the stuff he
said was good he said I [ __ ] up very
clearly and acknowledged what he did
um you know some of it was great for
sure you got you got maybe 30 seconds of
that yeah before twice being told how
rich he was and then again misdirection
into the number of people that are
trying it's like dude it's on your
shoulders yeah this wasn't in service of
anything that was outside of your
control like you're the person that
chooses how what happens with your
business you're the person that chooses
what have happens with your self-esteem
you're the person that's controlling the
inputs and outputs that you have within
your own life you're not even restricted
monetarily or in terms of resources you
can't even say you know I needed the
money it's like you said in second 25 of
the video that you were Rich before you
even started doing this yeah like this
was completely elective right
um yeah but at the beginning he says I
[ __ ] up like I own this
I thought it was a really bad move to
not put it on his Instagram in full I
think it was incredibly contrived to
take the most vague
portion of the video that is on YouTube
clip that put it as a reel on Instagram
and if people didn't know about the
story it gives him culpable deniability
and it doesn't sort of stries and affect
the problem any further and then the
YouTube channel that only has like 200
000 Subs I mean the video's done two mil
by the time that we're speaking which is
a lot but
if he put it on his Instagram uh
storyshares extra exposure that's his
primary platform of growth but he didn't
put the full video on there well why
it's not because of platform limitations
it's because he didn't want the exposure
yeah I think longer videos you can have
it in real format still right like it's
still the exact same push as a short
video and yeah that's definitely notable
I don't know like I definitely think his
Brands Will Survive and I think he will
uh you know continue to have his
followers that are
um like ultimately a lot of the stuff he
does talk about is positive and I do
think people would benefit from some of
the things he preaches but it's just I
don't know the way he calculated this
out meticulously and went about
deceiving people it was just hard to
wrap your head around
as a Justified move at the end of the
day just how many drugs was he on like
what did the sort of dosage is for those
of us that aren't uh a part of the off
the top of my head there is igf-1 CJC
ipamerelin uh mk677 GH Winstrol Deca
test so eight
and that's you know just going into the
you know the the questionnaire of trying
to just say this is what I'm doing right
now but I need Next Level and I need to
you know figure this stuff out now he
was trying to figure out how why all of
the GH related stuff he was using was
not working because he does I believe
have a unique genetic predisposition
that makes it harder to produce igf-1 or
with some of the other drugs he was
using that were kind of inhibiting it
but what gives you that sense well
because igf was less than 100 which is
reflective of somebody who is
like chronically malnourishing
themselves potentially
um and like uh I don't know chronically
keto dieting potentially fasting way too
much like he's not representative of
somebody who's in uh like a growth State
necessarily what makes you think that
that is something which is uh inherent
to him and not a byproduct of the
lifestyle that he's leading
ah because when you're using that much
[ __ ] it's really hard to imagine that
you wouldn't manually be putting your
igf-1 way higher like there's like he's
a smart [ __ ] guy even though he dumbs
himself down on podcasts to come across
as more relatable and make it more
understanding for
um the people he's trying to inspire or
whatever because some of the stuff he
would talk about otherwise is
complicated especially when it comes to
you know the like I don't know
biomarkers and endocrine hormones and
what kind of impacts certain foods have
like he very much
dials it down to be as palatable and
comprehensive and uh I don't know like a
palatable for the average person
um but I don't know like just the the
low value was something that he couldn't
even wrap his head around like that's
one of the motivations that he was
seeking uh guidance on essentially like
why am I on all this [ __ ] it's not
working well I suppose that's one of the
framings where you could have gone look
uh I think that there's something
physiologically going on here I've kind
of got myself into this strange feedback
cycle of taking more drugs to fix a
problem which potentially means that it
shuts down production more which makes
Modric yeah
that wasn't really the nature of the
emails that was a part of the emails but
the majority of the emails was yeah it
was driving the brand and just getting
virality yeah
yeah I just uh yeah it would have been
uh more ethical of him to disclose what
he was going to do with it and then give
the opportunity for whoever he is trying
to contact for guidance to decide from
there
I'm okay with that in the way you're
gonna do it versus not do I want to be
the rocket fuel for this ship that's
going to be stratospheric yeah it's like
obviously you're not the one on camera
doing it but like you're very much
providing guidance and endorsing the
process that he's doing that's the first
time that I've heard that taken I think
it's a really interesting one like that
that's a really interesting ethical
dilemma for somebody to be in like if
you want to synthesize the smallpox
virus so that someone can study it in a
lab or synthesize the smallpox virus so
someone can weaponize it and send it out
into the world
yeah yeah it's not quite the same but
yeah
um do you believe that he's now on a
therapeutic dose of 100 milligrams of
test per week
um well it's 120 but even I would if he
doesn't put up blood work regularly
which well you know he has no obligation
to I'm sure people would like it though
so they can know he's uh you know
representing the ancestral lifestyle
well and isn't walking around with a
stressed out liver and kidneys and
[ __ ] up markers and stuff
um I'm sure he is probably doing
something that he believes to be
more therapeutic than blasting his face
off but it is uh
if you're maintaining that physique
whatever you're doing is clearly not
representative of physiologic
replacement like even guys who were
because he's not got smaller yeah like
if you're if you're on 120 milligrams
depending on where your test levels land
it might not be therapeutic replacement
like for context again like I've seen
the guy's blood work and
it's
some of these levels they will sustain
themselves in perpetuity essentially
because of the way the drug is released
into the bloodstream like it's a long
Ester and you are not having any dips
following a diurnal Rhythm through
normal pulsatile secretions which
happens endogenously when you have
natural testicular output of
testosterone like normally you would
have test levels go up in the morning
they would dip kind of like go up and
down up and down and you would not have
a disproportionately high free tea
testosterone that is supporting enhanced
amounts of muscle mass whereas when
you're on exogenous trt even if you have
you're training twice a day or you're
you know getting shitty sleep or you go
out drinking or whatever it is like your
levels stay exactly where you want them
to they don't dip they don't change and
you have a disproportionately high free
tea so even though on paper it might
look like you're in the reference range
like it might not be representative of
that and that's not to say he is or
isn't in the reference range because
he's definitely been
[ __ ] he's deaf he's definitely holding
something that is unsustainable if he
came off everything put it that way yeah
I mean that was the conversation you
originally had with mata's Fitness right
so for people who don't know Matt's this
big Fitness YouTuber who's in really
really great condition and he wanted to
come to you to get uh the most highly
scrutinized
um type of blood work at a Cadence that
you thought was good enough for him to
be able to prove his natural status yeah
and uh the issue that you had or the
concern that you had is if we start to
do these tests a randomized frequency
and your condition begins to change or
the lift that you've got begin to change
or we see some anomalies within the
blood results yeah if there's no
anomalies and if your condition stays
the same we can be pretty reliable at
knowing that right now you are not
taking anything to enhance
it seems like liver King's just getting
linearly bigger and leaner and drier at
the moment yeah I think he's probably
plateaued by now but yeah in your
mid-40s you don't walk around like that
and you don't hold that when you are
working out twice a day
you know have been spread so thin
entrepreneurially having a family to
support et cetera et cetera like you
know again he doesn't have that much
historical
photos anyways to check his progress and
like when things you know picked up
heavily but like you very much kind of
elucidates himself what I think is
representative of Prior liver King where
it's like my cruise dose is this even
though you're coming into uh like this
is me coming to you from square one this
was my cruise dose heavily implying I
have blasted because you would never say
Cruise dose if you're not a guy who
blasts oh okay if it was just HRT you
would just say HRT but it wasn't
therapeutic do you believe because he
stays in the well again I don't want to
misconstrue like 0.60 sees a task could
very much be therapeutic like I'm not
saying that's high it very much depends
on what a cheap symptom relief what your
levels again like the levels on a piece
of paper are kind of just arbitrary at
the end of the day
it's about what if you had primary
hypogonadism and you needed trt Whatever
Gets you to
symptom relief is probably what you need
even if it some guys need more than what
liver King takes and testosterone dose
but I'm just saying that the context in
which she presents it very much implies
that previous to even the request for
how do I optimize my igf-1 and take you
know why is the GH not doing what I
think it's going to do there was to
build the physique where he got like
there was a blast thing involved so you
believe because he he says in uh his
apology that he was natural for 36 years
of training twice a day seven days a
week you kind of yeah I don't know why
he put that in like he makes it sound
like he just started hormones like right
at that time it's like well then your
physique would have morphed by it from
then to now and
you know it's just not representative of
that and it was just more so the
verbiage too because again you would you
would never say I cruise if you're if
you just started HRT you wouldn't even
know what the [ __ ] cruising blasting is
you know it's just very well maybe it
would but it's like you would never use
that verbiage unless it implies this is
my Baseline to try and hold on to what I
have but when I'm pushing the envelope
it's something else
it would be very interesting to see
because it's not like although the liver
King as a what was he called before
Barbarian lad yeah well that was like a
primal boy I don't I don't know who
deemed that to be his you know whatever
like that wasn't chosen by him because
he clearly identified himself from as
liver King from even where's the
Barbarian land thing come from
it was like a viral video on Facebook I
got tagged in okay it was the first one
I ever saw okay
um my point being even though that was
the Genesis of the character that he
plays literally talking about WWE guy
here yeah um
I feel like he could have just shown up
at least with a shirt on to the to the
YouTube video he like come across as
more like this is Brian talking yeah
make sure that I get a pump on before I
do this video about how I took loads of
steroids to get this physique yeah
um but yeah he he existed beforehand
right so there will be there has to be
no one no one's a [ __ ] digital ghost
so
there has to be
um physique progressions over time so
even if you're not going to come out and
do blood tests why not maybe say look
here's me at um 33 years old yeah 33
years old you can see I've already got
the muscle insertions I've got the size
I've got the dryness I've got the
fullness this proves that I haven't been
taking drugs for this long
or is it that some of the
um pretty sort of malignant looking
blood work results are a byproduct of
how much juice it took to get you to
this stage
yeah no uh I don't know if that would
ever like there are images of Emery
looks much smaller it's just few and far
between
um I don't know if his team like did a
[ __ ] scrub of the internet before he
started who knows I don't know how well
planned it was because again like you it
didn't seem like the whole thing was
Forward Thinking at all to begin with
anyways so it's kind of hard to
speculate on that what do you think the
future's got in store for him
um I think as long as he remains fully
transparent but I don't know like again
I don't think he is fully transparent
even after the apology but still I think
that overarchingly there will be a
subsect of people who really very much
feel that it was a you know a necessary
evil potentially to get the message out
more or people just don't care because
they find him highly entertaining or
um I do think that he continues to grow
on social media and uh make wild
ancestrally consistent videos and [ __ ] I
don't I don't think it changes that much
like he definitely is going to carry
this with him and people generally at
least know the truth behind the
Inception of the brand now and what the
plan was from day one Etc but
um I very much think it continues a
little bit on the same track all but
with
more transparency to some extent there's
been something weird that's happened
over the last few days since the video
that you released went out and it is
um a lot of Instagram stories from him
tagging you uh in this sort of
appreciative uh almost collaborative or
attempting I think to position himself
as collaborative with you uh to not
position himself in any way as an
adversary of yours like that's the
number one thing there was a video of
him that you must have seen sat around
the table with his kids at dinner yeah
saying uh you know before we eat like I
want to say thank you to Derek for doing
whatever he said um you're the Catalyst
to help bring him to his knees and rise
to new heights that he's eternally
grateful for what do you what do you do
you feel uh you feeling the gratitude
it's dude I don't know what he says is
part of the character or not at this
point so it's like I don't necessarily
think it comes from like a totally
honest Place necessarily as you would
expect but
um I understand why he would be doing it
to you know he's if he aligns with the
video and makes it seem like he's great
has his gratitude for it coming out and
it helps him you know be a more
transparent and better man in the future
than like what else I don't know what
else he could position it as or just not
talk about it at all I don't know what
do you think I don't even know what to
think about it dude like wrapping my
head around the whole situation is
strange it's very strange I think
um it makes sense to use it as a
a defensive strategy
um for all that on the outside he looks
relatively unflappable the apology video
to me held very little vulnerability or
sadness in it it didn't seem authentic
it didn't make me feel uh like any
sympathy for him
um
there still must be a lot of frenetic we
need to fix this we need to come up with
a solution to order to stop this not
even just there is a person in there
right there is a human in there for whom
this is going to be a difficult time
like and I do want to recognize the fact
that this will [ __ ] suck personally
for him
um
so it's not like every single thing is a
contrived business activity and he's
literally like the mouthpiece puppet of
a business that he also happens to run
yeah but
I think the reason that he would do it
that he is trying to align himself so
closely with you with Instagram stories
with the Gratitude with the Rave rise to
new Greater Heights and all of that
stuff
is in an attempt to
um down regulate the in-group out group
dynamic that weaponizes people on the
internet like that is what causes people
to really [ __ ] dig their heels into
something so if he was to say Derek's a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
um he shouldn't have released those
emails I think that it's unethical uh a
A stonewalled or lied or said like I'm
gonna whatever whatever like if he'd
done any of that the entire internet
would have got behind you they would
have said
you've just been rumbled and we're going
to take you down for it the only way
that you can deal with this is to be the
very gracious very humble very accepted
and to not position yourself as someone
that is on the other side of this
discussion to the person who has a
massive amounts of respect a huge
massive loyal fan base and is generating
like 2 million players a day on their
YouTube channel from one video like you
can't do that and I think that uh that
closeness and Affinity is a a protective
mechanism I'm not saying that that is
exclusively contrived either like I
genuinely think that you're just like I
don't know whether you ever did this in
school did you ever get um you would
accidentally like play too hard and hit
someone and they would start crying and
then you'd go ah and you'd start crying
as if you'd been hit as well like I see
this happening with kid little kids all
the time that they just
they want to try and find Affinity with
the person that is maybe a little bit of
an adversary and that that tries to calm
down the the energy a bit
yeah ah yeah it's hard to say man like
wrapping my head around the situation is
like I I don't really know what to make
of it sometimes when I think about the
whole picture it's just mind-blowing
this is even a thing seems like a like a
movie almost it's just it's just absurd
I've seen uh a couple of interesting
takes coming out of the ancestral slash
paleo slash Carnival Community uh saying
people already think that we're like
weird
I know her as it is like this was
Michaela's point right that she said
like everyone already looks at carnivore
and blind date people and thinks that
they're freaks
um like this guy is not making our job
any easier yeah of assisting people with
autoimmune disorders or whatever it is
that they're trying to fix with a
particular diet um he's not making it
any easier
no I guess yeah because again it's if
you have to make an excuse for why you
did this whole marketing strategy around
your brand but you have this Noble
intentions that are underpinning the
whole thing and that's why you did it
and then it's like all the other
carnivore people have to then say no
trust me the diet actually is useful for
certain people and that's not a
representation of why we do it or why
we'd recommend it or whatever
um yeah I can imagine it would be kind
of a weird thing to navigate for them
it's a little bit of a like a trolley
problem you know it's the net benefit of
this guy the nine ancestral tenants that
seem pretty [ __ ] good you know like I
rely on a bunch of them myself although
not through him yeah um
how much of that good information
ultimately is tarnished by coming from a
place of
uh contrived uh fundamentally
not natural uh foundations
um I guess definitely I I think a lot
like I said I think a lot of the the
tenants are quite useful and I think
would highly benefit a lot of people's
lives it's just the issue is that he
does not necessarily live them himself
like he to some extent yeah but it's
like oh your cell phone next to your
dick and ball is going to kill your
testosterone it's like well you're on
testosterone like
how much did that work no concerns about
that yeah and you know I'm
I'm fairly certain now again I don't
know his entire medical history but it
would be I would be surprised if he
actually you know needed all the stuff
that he's doing like I'm sure the guys
like Paul saladino are a good
representation of here's my blood work
on an actual carnivore diet and what it
can do for you before and after and why
I believe it to be effective and yeah he
kind of leans in the more viral route
for reals and stuff nowadays which some
people frown upon like Lane Norton some
of the guys in the nutrition space who
otherwise think Paul is to Tunnel
visioned on demonizing certain things to
propel his message a bit more but he's a
very very intelligent and I think
um
represents it to probably the most
to as ethical of a degree as he could
while also simultaneously selling
supplements and stuff because no matter
what you're gonna have people saying oh
you're a sellout you're a single
salesman whatever like once you start
selling anything that supports your
thing that you're also a the the
front-facing spokesperson for so and
that's you know and not necessarily a
fair take when there is act I think
there is utility of things like like
beef liver capsules if you hate the
taste of it by all means take a take a
supplement like who cares it's just the
marketing behind it at least Paul is at
least uh forthcoming about like this is
why you would use it it's not going to
make you you know Jack bodybuilder who
looks like a WWE character but it might
make you healthier because of the
micronutrients kind of thing when we're
talking about testosterone generally uh
I'm hearing a lot more about guys going
on trt uh in America it seems to be
significantly bigger than it is in the
UK which is where I'm from originally
what are the health risks that guys
should consider if they're thinking
about going on trt someone comes to you
and says hey man I'm whatever at an age
where I feel like this is something that
I want to do what should I be concerned
about what would you tell them
well it depends the context in which
they enter into that because again if
you don't actually need it and you get
on it you could be making yourself
less healthy if you're already perfectly
functioning top tier and you're just
doing it because I know you want to look
like liver king or some [ __ ] like I
don't know but if you don't if you do
need it and you're clinically deficient
you are and again not a non-medical
advice but in general you're going to be
more prone to things like cardiovascular
disease neurodegeneration Etc so it's
kind of like if you actually clinically
need something to then
say what is the downside to trt it's
like what is the downside of not being
on trt at that point potentially
that's the kind of how I would frame it
for the actual clinical utility of it in
a real deficient setting it's kind of
like what could you be staving off by
using it in a responsible way it's kind
of and again I think this is where like
Brian could come in and be educating and
actually say this is you know like he
knows why stuff is actually useful and
healthy or has actual utility in a
clinical setting but he very much you
know foregoes that because it just
doesn't uh
fit the well up the now it hadn't fit
the narrative essentially
would you be surprised if the volume of
drugs that it's likely that he's taken
wouldn't have taken a little bit of uh
time off his health span oh for sure
yeah it's definitely not conducive to
longevity
the bigger you are the more muscle you
have okay this is too vague of a
statement because I was about to say if
you have too much muscle
you're just gonna die quicker in general
humans who are bigger and have more
demands from their organs to support
their infrastructure or going to
live a shorter amount of time in general
like to like a small tiny Asian woman is
probably going to outlive the Jack
brontosaurus human that's on a
bodybuilding stage every single time why
because of the stress and Taxation it
takes to support the demands of that
tissue so and also it depends how
regulating you are of things like blood
pressure are you letting it get out of
whack do you have a resting heart rate
of like is it are you like borderline
tachycardia all the time with 100
resting heart rate and you're never
getting to sleep because you're so
jacked up on androgens or like whatever
like there are so many things that play
into it it's multifactorial for sure but
in general if you are just a and again
this isn't to say because there is
definitely a push in the longevity
Community to be protein deficient and be
as small as possible and be frail and
just live a terrible life but live to
100 plus like there needs to be a happy
medium in my opinion for a high quality
of life that's also trying to live as
long as possible with that high quality
because you're gonna die eventually and
do you want those years to be you know
frail like barely [ __ ] functional in
a chair probably not so there's
definitely a happy medium but in general
the uh the more you go super physiologic
the less healthy it is in all areas is
kind of the best way to put it that's a
really good take and I totally know what
you mean with regards to the balance
between longevity uh amount of years and
quality of those
um do you want to feel good perform well
be able to do a variety of tasks and be
able to live life to its fullest or do
you want to permanently be in this
ambient anxiety about whether or not
your oxalate level has gone through the
roof because you didn't eat the right
type of spinach this morning like
that is I think one of the concerns I I
dug into the longevity Community for a
long time and Dr David Sinclair's been
on twice and went to go meet him in
Harvard and it was just after he'd been
on Rogan and then I went to go and see
him in Boston the week after that he's
getting a lot of heat recently I've had
yeah people think he's coordinating with
the FDA to get nmn banned in the
supplement industry I think that's true
I haven't looked into this at all I
haven't looked into it enough but there
is pretty damning suggestive things that
don't look too favorable and are people
um
like attached to the access to nmn yeah
it's like I don't even know if it has
that much utility at the end of the day
but it's just the fact that he's trying
to restrict people so then he can
benefit from interesting potentially
again yeah yeah allegedly I haven't I've
sold one headline about this and didn't
I haven't read it yet but it makes you
also wonder is it just because he's a
big name that then has monetary upside
now that automatically equals he's a
piece of [ __ ] because that's often when
people start making money off something
that they were otherwise just talking
about with seemingly no bias or
financial incentive Etc you know he's
very much been on many podcasts and made
it seem like you know I don't
necessarily recommend it it's just what
I do but it literally says uh when
people ask what nmn do you take and he's
like yeah like I don't have a
recommendation he actually ended up I
think starting to say Life by Nature was
the one that he began using after a
while something tells me the only reason
that he gave up any brand that he uses
was simply because he was sick of being
asked which brand it is that he used it
was like a [ __ ] take anything from me
yeah it's a wild and odd scenario that I
feel like the maybe not the exact same
but like huberman or Sinclair they often
find themselves in a weird situation
where they'll talk about something they
feel is promising but they're so
influential that it then Spurs people
trying to buy it as you would expect and
then when they ask him for his
recommendation he's like do I just tell
you a brand or are you gonna then think
I have some sort of like well also you
you're adding in I've done the due
diligence about Tanga Ali and fidojia
regressus let's say and I've looked at
the the data on the back end of that
you're gonna then ask me for a
supplement recommendation off the back
of that which now requires me to go and
do a whole [ __ ] ton more investigation
in order to see whether double words or
gorilla mode or like what whatever it is
is like the optimal product for me to go
and take so I I understand the
hesitation around that but when I first
spoke to David and the longevity our
slash longevity Reddit was going off
it's a very passionate community in a
way that few others are and I wonder how
much of the longevity communities like
real
vehement
um Obsession and uh passion for it is
kind of like a denial of death thing
that
inbuilt into the longevity Community you
have to assume that there is a a large
minority maybe more of people who have
found that as a techno-utopia secular
equivalent of trying to find eternal
life that you would have done previously
spiritually and if someone comes in and
says starts to either criticize the
community or restrict their access to
supplements that they think is going to
like get them to the promised land
they're going to respond in kind yeah
yeah it's like
if you designed something from scratch
like I how nmn came to be
you know it's just like a basic thing
that could be derived from like like for
example nicotinic acid or niacin or any
of these things that are very very
overlapping these are readily available
as supplements so I don't really know
how the hype behind nmn came to be if it
was just Sinclair or what but it's
definitely uh
I don't know it's uh problematic when
you know that the price of it is
probably going to be exorbitantly higher
than the supplement itself because it's
going to be from pharmaceutical
standards and prescribed to you and then
it's going to involve some hiked up
hiked up amount that it costs Etc and
um yeah like I can I can see why he's
getting backlash regardless even if he
feels like he deserves the monetary
upside and he doesn't want to publicly
say it like he might very much feel like
I'm the only created the hype [ __ ] you
guys I'm gonna capitalize on it that's
an interesting position yeah I mean we
were talking about this over dinner last
night about the
unbelievable degree of influence that
certain uh guys have got hell especially
in the health and fitness space and uh
Max lugave was on the show and his
nutrition scientist and I was like bro
why is nutrition signs such a mess why
is it the case everybody every single
person on the planet eats multiple times
per day how can it be that it's so
contested and the the point is that when
you can
manipulate studies to be able to fit
whatever kind of narrative or rhetoric
it is that you want you're always going
to get the opportunity for [ __ ] from
people they're always going to be able
to slide themselves in to different bits
and pieces there
um go back to the testosterone
conversation
men's testosterone dropping one percent
per year since the 1980s and they're at
all-time record lows and stuff like that
is this something that we should be
worried about do you think yeah for sure
definitely
why is it happening
um I think you're in your opinion I
think it's multifactorial and it is a
combination of Lifestyle
environmental exposure
um
diet choices lack of exercise poor
lifestyle habits sedentary jobs now no
exposure to sunlight being indoors all
the time more people are depressed from
social media too like there's just so
many things that are conducive to being
a sedentary lazy apathetic piece of [ __ ]
basically and these are not conducive to
masculinity or making testosterone
obviously right do you agree I I do I I
don't know the way that uh testosterone
production can be influenced by
environmental factors oh yeah if you see
uh like a a hot chick all T goes up uh I
found out that it goes up if you're
around weapons there you go yeah if
you're near a gun yeah so that's an
advisor for keeping lots of weapons I
suppose in your house and touching them
regularly yeah wake up and just [ __ ]
broken guns on the morning but um I I I
don't know how big the impact can be
right on
um human physiology simply from what
you're talking about
lack of sleep in itself can just [ __ ]
destroy you and a lot of people are
perpetually five to six hours with poor
quality sleep have we got data that
people's sleep has uh decreased uh their
quality of sleep and the length of sleep
has decreased over time you'd have to
defer to Matthew Walker on that for like
an exact statistic but I'm fairly
certain that you could confidently say
in general Sleep Quality and duration is
deteriorated in recent years quite
significantly yeah well it's interesting
to think that um
we could be our environment could be the
architect of this downfall if there was
one thing that you would just if you had
to put money on a roulette of what are
the biggest contributors
what where is the burrito for this or
what is making the biggest impact what
would be up there maybe sleep touching
receipts
you're rubbing it all over yourself last
night yeah I saw you no it's uh I would
say dipping your balls in it yeah I
shouldn't have done that uh I think it
was uh mainly the the bad sleep I think
is very very impactful and a lot of
people are in a perpetually
trying to compensate state for their
poor sleep with
over consumption of stimulants caffeine
Etc to make up for the shitty sleep
which the half-life of these drugs is
bleeding into the night when you're
trying to get to sleep and it's just
this vicious circle of a disaster that
results in low
low hormone output and it's [ __ ]
terrible dude and then there's you know
the diets have been pretty bad in recent
years in terms of like quality and
choice of foods you know people are
going to stuff that's not even food like
what is something that is fake and taste
good but doesn't have any micronutrient
density there's that and just like
General General low-hanging fruit as
much as they're obvious very much get
neglected okay okay let's say someone's
listening and they go this Brian guy
doesn't seem like my bag going to take
an ass full of steroids I want to get
myself to as healthy a level of
testosterone naturally using lifestyle a
diet and maybe non-clinical
supplementation as I can what's the
prescription this is not medical advice
oh my god dude that's so General I I
could what would you do if you were to
say I would be like what are the
principles that people should follow I
would say getting to bed at the same
time every night ideally and waking up
at the same time every morning following
your circadian rhythm you know as it
starts to get dark you start to wind
down you get to bed at an adequate time
hopefully around you know
depending on what where you live your
schedule Etc but ideally no later than
like 11 or 12
um getting up as the sun's coming up
it's not always going to be you know
perfect like that but I mean just
following your circadian rhythm in
general very very much aligns with the
diurnal Rhythm that your like pulsatile
secretion of hormones would follow and
when you start to manipulate that in
like a artificial way and trying to I
don't know putting yourself in
situations that are not conducive to
high quality sleep it's you know bright
outside you're trying to go to bed or
whatever you don't have blackout blinds
like there are ways to try and hack it
but at the end of the day I think that
even when I track my sleep metrics when
I go to bed at 10 pm versus 2 A.M like
it's a dramatic difference in terms of
quality I feel like in general and um
I don't think anyone actually has a full
clear answer on that by the way because
I've asked guys like huberman and stuff
about if I go to bed at 2AM but I sleep
eight hours and I have blackout blinds
and I optimize everything could I get
the same Health outcomes as if I was you
know a dialed in like 9 30 p.m sleep
what would be the difference between
that and just going to another time zone
basically the only thing you would maybe
do is restrict the amount of daylight on
the back end because obviously nighttime
is going to arrive sooner if you've got
up a little bit later so you're going to
restrict the amount of daylight that you
got but even if you could compensate
with that by going right okay I'm going
to over expose myself to sunlight during
the day or to Daylight then yeah that
would be interesting like your body's
pretty intuitive and oftentimes I think
it knows better than you do like when
people try and hack their body sometimes
they're fighting against something that
is not leading to an optimal outcome and
they could have otherwise just been
following the common principles of go to
bed at a good time after the sun goes
down get up at the same time every
morning sort of following you know the
normal circadian rhythm that a human
should follow
um I'm not saying you have to do it but
that's what I would generally recommend
okay that's sleep yeah sleep is sorted
what else is someone doing optimal
testosterone naturally a good proportion
of like not depriving yourself entirely
of fats in your diet because some people
will very much especially in the fitness
space will go protein carbs they very
much want to try and hit their body
weight in protein and then they'll have
carbs but then they will neglect fat
content which can be detrimental to
testosterone and that's often overlooked
even people are eating adequate calories
they are sometimes depriving themselves
of basic things like one man
macronutrient entirely or micronutrient
density like one of the things I do is I
plug my diet into this thing called
chronometer it's kind of like my fitness
pal but it's uh more comprehensive and
then it breaks down all of the
micronutrients and minerals of your
Foods so it shows what vitamins and
minerals you're deficient in of your
diet model and then you can then
backfill accordingly based on what
you're deficient in WoW so that is
typically what I would recommend too
because if you don't have the cofactors
and substrate to actually produce the
hormones even if you're eating
what you consider to be a good diet it
might be deficient in adequate zinc or
it might be deficient and adequate
bioavailable B vitamins or whatever like
it would be worthwhile to kind of at
least one time like flesh out if you
follow a consistent diet what does that
yield in terms of all of the vitamins
and minerals and is that satisfactory
for optimal hormone output and that's
where you can then determine like actual
targeted supplementation
because oftentimes people are blindly
taking [ __ ] like oh I think I need zinc
so I'll just take this compensating for
malnutrition in one form or another with
supplementation if you need to like I
have obviously food Whole Foods is in
general I would say going to be better
but it depends because some people don't
want to eat more some people have goals
that are you know body fat related and
they want to maybe even restrict
calories and at that point you might be
cutting something out that was hitting
your micronutrient allotment for some
specific thing and that's where you
would then supplement potential so there
is a
like a tension between
calories calories in and the
micronutrients that you begin to cut
calories to the point where you can't
eat enough to be able to get the
micronutrients in depending on what your
goals are because again some people
don't care about getting you know as
lean as you for example come on uh okay
so we've got food we've got sleep
um what else what else is in there is
the big movers for testosterone
production
um I guess far as environmental
stressors and whatnot it's hard for me
to quantify like all the chlorine in
your [ __ ] showers killing your tests
like I don't know for sure but I would
probably Edge against have you got a
special filter yeah sure do you yeah
what brand is it do you know
I don't know but you can just search
like chlorine filter shower head
chlorine filter or something or is this
um yeah probably like you could probably
vet out a good one within with a little
bit of research don't rely on me for
that I don't even know if mine's the
best one but I remember when I was
looking for it it seemed to be like I
would very much do a lot of the same
research as other people or thinking
like okay uh YouTube who who do I trust
in the industry that otherwise has made
videos on this content and is otherwise
already dissected the literature okay
does that guy know what he's talking
about okay let me cross-reference it
against a couple other people that I
trust in our educated boom and then you
kind of create a conclusive educated
guess as to what is the best do they
have monetary upside from promoting this
thing are they sponsored blah blah blah
go look at the Amazon reviews does it
look favorable you know obviously stuff
can be manipulated you can't ever fully
trust anything I guess but I mean you
gotta do you just do your due diligence
and try and do what you can what other
environmental factors apart from yeah
um
off the top of my head like I know uh I
don't know how impactful the receipts
thing is stop touching the seats son
yeah that's what I'm telling you so that
I guess
um what else uh oh cooking in like like
plastics for I think is something that
could be impacted not cooking like
heating stuff up and like storing stuff
and drinking out of plastic bottles not
ideal yeah okay we are killing I'm
traveling I would normally have a glass
bottle but uh uh yeah one thing that I
found is a really nice solution for that
um a bunch of different companies make
glass Tupperware yeah plastic lid glass
uh sides which I'm gonna guess is mostly
okay because the food's not going to be
touching the top yeah all my prep meals
are in glass containers really nice
super easy to clean don't smell as much
uh if you do end up leaving it for a few
days you don't feel like oh God it's
infused into the Container now and I've
permanently got this sort of moldy
residue that's going to be in there yeah
um steel shakers yeah for uh using uh
protein and whatnot
probably some sort of cooler as well
would be steel I'd be interested to know
I'm gonna guess that Yeti and and
companies like that have done a good bit
of research into
um other metals leaking in at all is
there any any risk of that uh Ben
Greenfield was on the show and he was
telling me that uh xevia xevious the
sweet drink right
um he had the one of the product
development managers at that place on
and they they used a special type of
aluminum that uh was leaking less
aluminum
aluminum I'm British son we actually
have an extra I was a double jerking I
know what you're talking about
come on now come on you're Canadian come
on do I say stuff weird sometimes
bits and pieces that's a boot apparently
do you are you very polite
I think yeah well I the one one of my
good friends uh Dr Steve McGill I landed
off a plane and the first thing he said
to me when I got to Canada was how are
you good he says and how have my
countrymen been to you have they been
polite and I was like is this are you is
this like a joke or is this real and
it's like I was like yeah perfectly
black it's a good good I'm going on with
this day so apparently um uh genetically
predisposed to being polite but uh yeah
the yeah sorry the [ __ ] metal the
metal that's in the drink right the
metal that's in the xevia can is uh
they've looked at formulating that in
different ways so people are certainly
coming around to it but I was walking
through Whole Foods with a bunch of
friends that are um big into the health
and fitness anti-seed oil
anti-estrogens and everything etc etc
and I was like uh what about that can I
have that and they're like no I can't
have that can't have that kind of that
it's like what about those candles over
there and they said no full of estrogens
can't have that uh [ __ ] incense over
there that's got it in so if you
actually want to adequately assess the
impact of these things though like again
how impactful are they at the end of the
day like even things like your lifestyle
your exercise regimen all super
impactful above and beyond the Sleep the
diet the exposure to all these toxins
Etc
doing blood work I think is absolutely
warranted to have a baseline as early as
possible where it's you know your Peak
hormone output you know 21 25 years old
have some sort of Baseline profile that
is comprehensive so then if something
goes awry you can then go back and
identify where there are deficiencies
and balances Etc what went wrong and why
so some of these exposures to whatever
it is that's detrimental to testosterone
or lackluster fill in the blank
if you change that you could then get
blood work done to assess is my
gonadotropin output now sufficient
compared to before if it was sub-optimal
you can see pretty clearly like rather
than being speculative about
does this help maybe I should totally
change this area of my life because it
might be sub-optimal like there are some
things that might be you don't want to
do that you think are going to be
conducive to better hormones and maybe
it has no impact whatsoever and at that
point you could go get a basic
testosterone test marichealth.com
you could go there that would be that
would be a worthwhile place to go I'll
do your rad reads for you tomorrow
thanks bro I appreciate it um we spoke
about Andrew cubman today what's your
thoughts on him his contributions
um overarchingly is one of the best
educational resources I would say that
is
um also one of the only individuals that
I believe to be very very
uh I don't know like dedicated to
putting out the best information even at
the detriment of potential views like he
will not just host people who will get
high views he will host people that he
feels are have high level contribution
to the community at large and are
educational and could otherwise inform
him of things he doesn't even know and
he's very open to criticism even from
YouTubers who aren't medically qualified
like myself like he did not get upset or
annoyed when I first uh reacted to one
of his uh Joe Rogan episodes and I had
talked about
um some of the stuff he said about uh
some of the bodybuilding drugs he had
mentioned some of the interactions with
endocrine hormones I kind of did one of
my classic reaction videos and gave kind
of my insight on what I felt to be
correct and he was very very polite in
like a lot of people could take that the
wrong way and be like I'm a [ __ ] like
world top tier neuroscientist and you
piece of [ __ ] YouTuber you don't know
anything who are you to talk about this
and he was not like that at all he you
know we've become decent friends I would
say since then he's uh I'm always open
to learning even if it's from people who
aren't like medically credentialed which
is awesome because there are a lot of
people out there who are some of the
people I learned the most from aren't
MDS or guys who are otherwise seen as
you know the Forefront
on paper qualified person there are
people who are just entrenched in
learning more and are otherwise very
much doing the same thing he does too
where they'll just host people and learn
or dig into literature themselves stay
up to date on most of the on the most
Cutting Edge developments in
endocrinology pharmacology whatever it
is and he's uh yeah he's great it seems
like a rarity to have someone that has
got the scientific rigor and the
preparedness to go through what I
imagine aren't exactly entertaining
papers not exactly like a riveting read
yeah um to then take all of that out
look at what does this mean for the
everyday person and then turn it into
something that's an applied solution
like that's an awful lot of work and you
know the podcast is unbelievably
successful and he has this fantastic uh
platform now and uh his live shows are
going well and all the rest of it but
like
let's be fair he works as part as
podcasters go that man Works incredibly
hard for what he gets out it's not like
he's publishing an episode every single
day yeah he's not live streaming all the
time he's taking weeks months sometimes
to do research for a single episode this
one's going to be about grief this one's
going to be about a mating psychology
this one's going to be about exercise
science or whatever like this guy's gone
as deep as is possible on pretty much
anything and everything that's available
to do it the interesting thing a massive
fan of Andrew
become really like tight with him since
he came on the show and I found him like
a really giving like kind person which
again for that industry you'd think like
super artisty uh just ahead in the books
without any compassion or whatever and
not the case either
the biggest difference or the
interesting thing that I realized I
think
since huberman's been on the scene
the biohacking community overall has
begun to look more and more silly to me
personally
um I don't know whether that's the case
for everybody else but the very sort of
experimental forward-thinking like super
out there stuff that was being done
kind of seems a bit silly and under
evidenced give me an example uh red
light stunning on your balls and like
claiming that that's like the biggest
thing the most important thing that you
need to do
um PCP injections into like whatever
whatever [ __ ] part of your body in
order to be able to facilitate that blah
blah blah like the um
different types of lights that people
would get either on glasses or around
their neck to activate certain glands or
whatever that I saw that was like a
thing for a big while these sort of um
necklaces almost that had lights built
into them that people would use like all
manner of wild [ __ ] that was happening
uh using uh like brain train EMF
machines in order to be able to optimize
your meditation practice and stuff like
that
in comparison with someone like huberman
who just comes out and goes this is what
the science says this is what we know
like hard and fast this is something
that has evidence that backs it up this
is a tool that we can
fairly derive from those conclusions
this is something that you should try
with an appropriate amount of caveats
and to me
it's thrown the biohacking community in
a quite harsh light some of the elements
of the biohacking community that were
super out there now that being said
there are a bunch a bunch of things that
I'm sure that uh Andrew suggests that
the biohacking community was light years
ahead on but if you throw a lot of [ __ ]
at the wall inevitably some of it's
going to stick and I think in for a um
like bang for your buck yeah per minute
content consumption versus usable
strategy I think that the signs are out
that Andrew goes down is just like
Second To None yeah and he's very quick
to correct himself he only says
something that's wrong like I saw your
podcast with him and he even like went
and commented I made a mistake at this
part like how many people do that yeah
it was his uh
preparedness to not be
it's psychologically attached to the
stuff that he puts out there is
something that I think we all probably
could learn a little bit from because
it's very difficult and this is where
I know that you know to bring
Brian back into it
it must be difficult to have
your entire public Persona get dragged
now whether it was a contrived Persona
in an attempt to sell products that were
built off the back of a body that was
created using
that is by the by however
it's not easy it's not easy to be
criticized online like it [ __ ] sucks
like the difference between me and my
work
and how people perceive that and my
worth as a person and whether or not I
am fundamentally a piece of [ __ ] is like
kind of hard you know what I mean yeah
do you feel this I mean you know you're
regularly stepping into all manner of
different contested topics is this
something that you feel as well
um yeah like it's uh what is what is the
overarching question that you're trying
to ask here like how do I feel about
Twitter system online okay I'm
personally involved with them yeah I
definitely read it and I probably should
be better about maybe not taking it so
personally when people are going to
disagree with you and sometimes you
could actually be wrong and
um you know I very much do acknowledge
when I'm incorrect on something and try
to be open to learning more and
um I don't know like I guess not being
so
dedicated to your way of wait your way
the highway is the only way is very
important to maintain I don't know
flexibility as a Creator and have the be
able to retain an audience long term and
have trust factor with them in that
you're not just dedicated to something
even at the detriment of it being wrong
or at their harm or something that you
then find out to be totally incorrect
like you know there's a lot of stuff
that
um back in the day I thought to be true
that ended up not being true and I
learned otherwise and you have to be
open to going back on that or else you
are not
a high quality resource I would say you
have to be very open to the criticism
and or learning more in general for sure
keeping the ego small and this is not
just for creators it's everybody right
everybody is uh
uh existentially passionately connected
to their point of view as a
representation of themselves especially
given that a lot of what people are
represented as on the internet now
other opinions like you are your takes
for a very like broad amount of time
like even the most old school of like
Facebook that is people are going to be
having takes on a platform which was
supposed to be photos for family and
[ __ ] like that yeah um so I understand
why
it's difficult to do it and I feel it in
myself as well
um but keeping your ego small and having
strong opinions loosely held not loose
opinions strongly held is
if you can get used to accepting that
you're wrong or accepting that you need
to correct your opinion course correct
the direction that you have with things
it's going to make progress way easier
because you're going to be able to
crowdsource if you're not existentially
like bothered about whether you're right
or wrong you're just simply trying to
seek truth you go well
I get to crowdsource all of my sense
making to everybody it's like as soon as
I get something wrong so thank you like
thank you for for informing me about
this thing now I know all of this [ __ ]
and I'm even better so criticism becomes
uh a an asset then as opposed to a
slight yeah no I think it's sort of in a
way why Rogan is so successful too
because he'll just he just wants to
learn he's not biased in what in how he
goes about it he's not having people on
for views he's not really doing anything
of that nature he just is highly
interested in something wants to learn
more thinks his audience would benefit
from it as well potentially has that
person on and just creates like this
Bank of just vast knowledge that is uh
invaluable and he's always open
correcting himself even self-deprecating
at times he's like I'm an idiot don't
listen to me
but he's like highly educated and become
extremely uh the scope of his knowledge
is just insane given the amount of
people you hosts and
um yeah it's like one of the coolest
things it's impossible not to man like
even whatever
550 600 episodes whatever this will be
um
just sheer time and attention of being
around smart interesting people you end
up even if you only take one percent of
what you've heard from someone you end
up with like so many I was at uh
Thanksgiving dinner with a mental
performance coach for a professional
Esports team wow and I was like oh we're
[ __ ] talking like me and you me and
you're like everybody else get out of
the way I've got a conversation with
this man and we had like an hour and a
bit conversation and there was loads of
stuff that it brought back up to do with
Michael Juve this guy that was a Felix
Baumgartner you know the dude that
jumped from space he had a problem with
his um uh he had claustrophobia when he
was getting inside of the suit and they
needed to get this Michael guy in to
come and like like [ __ ] pull the
record like we need to fix this guy or
else we're not gonna be able to go ahead
with the mission like thinking about
Concepts that I've learned from him or
Steve Magnus this guy that wrote another
book or like stories that I've heard
about Tiger Woods or Kobe Bryant or
whatever I'm like this isn't this is
just me repurposing some [ __ ] that
somebody else said to me but this one
guy in like what feels like an
unbelievably niche
uh industry yeah
you get to have this amazing
conversation and you know that's what
the attraction is to shows that I think
are diverse is everybody is such a
inherently
idiosyncratic varied individual I don't
know many people that are what do you
like I like Ultimate Frisbee and that's
it and it's like no I like like 20
things right I like like sci-fi from the
80s and I'm a fan of like modern art and
classical music and blah blah blah and
because of that you want to try and
reflect that in your content consumption
because it feeds all of those different
things and then obviously as a Creator
if you get to be the person that's like
who are you going to speak to this week
and go I don't know whoever I'm
interested in like no barriers yeah
that's that's what's cool and then
Downstream from that people get to learn
it as well did you get any good tips for
gaming
so your game uh I don't not anymore I
used to but nowhere near as like like I
was terrible even when I was trying okay
um but
the biggest things that he told me were
exactly the same things that you've just
brought up to do with testosterone I
asked him what the biggest problems that
his professionally Sports athletes face
are for them sleep and caffeine were he
was like if I could fix those two things
which are obviously both interlinked as
well
he said that would probably be
50 of his job Define fix for caffeine
like what does that involve these kids
who have only managed to get themselves
onto a professional Esports team by
grinding that all they do is grind right
they
perhaps unsurprisingly like some kid
playing Call of Duty at 13 isn't
thinking about a structured periodized
training plan which is what they're
going toward now with this mental
performance they're doing
um like Peak weeks they're having back
offs they're like all this stuff like
mental muscle the same as the physical
muscle or similar at least they're not
doing that so they get that
purely through grinding they're doing it
usually after school on a night time so
you have inculcated a particular type of
training practice which you then need to
say okay now it's time to be an adult
and or a professional
um please I want you to get up at 7am I
want you to do these things a lot of the
guys also stream on Twitch or have other
side hustles that involve or that have
incentives for them to create more
content than perhaps is optimal for
their training and
yeah it's a vicious feedback mechanism
these kids are sinking 300 400 milligram
caffeine drinks consistently throughout
the day to keep themselves going that
means their diet's not dialed in because
they're constantly suppressing their
appetite as they're going through this
[ __ ]
um and then they're staying up late
they're getting they're not getting any
sunlight very little movement and uh
he's now trying to fix these problems
an interesting difference is if you look
at a normal sport right let's say like
in American football which has its
problems CTE and blah blah but like for
the most part the training diet regimen
and game practice regimen that you go
through is actually making you a fit a
human like you're outside you have
Community you are lifting things moving
things cardio's getting work out you're
eating Whole Foods you're blah blah blah
blah like everything's styled right the
two most unhealthy Sports Esports and
bodybuilding
yeah good point well I mean talk to me
about that talk to me about the uh the
price that people are paying to do
modern bodybuilding now because it was a
period where
um if it's natural it could be healthy
by the way that's not to say yeah
overarchingly uh non-natural non-tested
federations of bodybuilding what is your
guess or knowledge even about these sort
of Health impacts that these guys are
having in order to achieve at the
absolutely top level like it's hard to
quantify but in general I would say if
you are pushing the envelope Full Tilt
in the open bodybuilding division you
would be lucky to make it past
45 years old if you are doing Full Tilt
bodybuilding the entire time you mean
like you'd be dead at 45 potentially
yeah like if you were going hard as from
like Teenage Hood to 45
blasting every single offseason weighing
up to 300 pounds you know cutting down
to you know 260 270 stand on stage you
know sometimes less depends on depends
on the height of the guy whatever I
think the top guys at the sport like I
would be impressed if they came out
at 45 years old retired and were like
still lived a normal duration of life
and is that common to if you have the
right genetics and you get picked up and
you start doing Junior shows as soon as
someone hits 18 19 20 21 is that the
sort of beginning of their use of
steroids uh in general a lot of guys
will
realize quite quickly that everyone
they're competing against even as low as
the entry-level shows are using [ __ ] and
then they feel compelled to do so as
well because to be competitive among
those guys
it's just like uh necessary evil
unfortunately there depending on your
genetics you might be able to get
somewhat far but once you get to the pro
ranks like you're not gonna win top
shows at all if you're natural it's just
impossible so let's say that someone
hasn't dropped out at 45 I'm gonna guess
in terms of health health outcomes being
able to live a normal life which isn't
assisted with a ton of drugs on the
outside is at a risk as well
yeah so and let me sort of circle back
to the the dying at 45 thing that's like
the war if somebody is Full Tilt
maintaining these high body weights
perpetually and doing it for you know 10
20 years and probably predisposed yeah
like some of these some guys will drop
in their 20s when they are in this uh in
Pro bodybuilding talking about uh Boston
Lloyd last night yeah obviously people
will use him as a outlier because his
use of drugs was so extreme and just
such uh
um he often would neglect even getting
Diagnostics to assess things and he just
I don't know like again I don't have all
the Insight on exactly what he was doing
or not doing but it seemed you know it
was a lot of uh
some mental issues around the the
compulsion to take certain things that
he knew was probably unhealthy but
anyway the bodybuilders that are trying
to live the lifestyle though and are
eating copious amounts of foods taking
the drugs that need to maintain the high
body weights like it's just it's just
unhealthy in general like there's
nothing Fitness or health conducive
about it at the end of the day that in
Esports too dangerous so yeah obviously
magnitude's different in terms of danger
but I mean like one is uh yeah
physically and mentally pretty
problematic and then the Esports thing
you know it was just the second thing I
could think of underneath that makes
sense to me man um there's obviously
more sports like obviously people are
gonna be like what about football people
crashing into each other with their
helmets on and stuff but UFC like
obviously there are things worse it was
just a quick remark but I think in terms
of the um like the byproduct of Simply
preparing for the sport it's pretty
difficult to say that there's anything
which is which gives you worse Health
outcomes I'll be interested to know it's
like the act of actually preparing is
not necessarily unhealthy when you are
in the middle of uh off season you're
training hard you're doing hopefully a
decent getting a decent step count still
eating your macro and micronutrients but
it's just when you get to the the super
physiological range of muscle tissue
that your body's supposed to hold it's
literally fighting back against you to
try and not hold as much size you're
using drugs that your body was never
meant to process it the amounts you're
injecting into yourself but you're
bypassing all the regulating feedback
systems such as Hamming yourself with
super physiological amounts
um like it's just anything above that
threshold you are getting into
escalating risk territory and like
obviously the natural bodybuilding in
itself other than the extreme weight
cutting and water depletion potentially
the act of natural bodybuilding is not
unhealthy like it's a very healthy thing
and I don't think the the general
bodybuilding shouldn't dissuade people
because it's unhealthy it's just the
drug use the excessive body weights and
the excess of eating they have to do to
achieve those body weights with the drug
use that is the most problematic so
you're saying that there is a a ceiling
to muscle carrying capacity that bodies
have and that you start to bounce off a
particular limiter because I've always
thought like why is it that you don't
have bigger variance in how particular
bodybuilders at the absolute top look on
stage like why don't you have people
that are
another 50 pounds bigger than everybody
else there sort of is some people like
there are have you ever seen big Grammy
I have yeah he could be classified as
yeah and is that um with somebody like
that he's maybe got like a what a like a
higher carrying capacity his body's
tolerance for being able to not destroy
muscle is greater than everybody else's
maybe uh it depends but there's
definitely like at the end of the day
it's a genetic thing because there's no
way he's necessarily working harder than
a guy who's coming in 10th Place maybe
maybe he is but there are a lot of guys
I know who work their [ __ ] asses off
and will never beat him even if they
probably work harder I'm not saying he
doesn't work hard but just in general
there are certain people no matter what
they do or how much drugs they take they
will never beat him even if they double
his drug dose it's just the genetic
predisposition it could be more muscle
fiber content from when he was
developing as a like literally in the
womb like that some of that stuff you
can't really compensate for just with
more drugs because you only have so much
infrastructure to build off of and
induce hypertrophy and so many muscle
cells that you can then try and do
things with and if you don't have that
infrastructure to get to the big Ramy
size like
it's just not going to happen but this
is like such a hyper outlier scenario
anyways like no one at the end of the
day the takeaway for the average person
who can you know relate to this because
we're not bodybuilders the people
watching probably aren't you know
top-tier bodybuilders so
um I try to keep the the context of this
more relatable for the the average
person like ultimately drugs at Super
physiological super physiological doses
there's no situation in which it is uh
you're not going to have some trade-off
for its use essentially there's always a
give and take when it comes to Peds
talking about bro signs what's your
thoughts on nofap
ah these go viral always the nofap
conversations I think that it is
it depends what you are doing it for are
you doing it because you've been told by
I know some like incel Forum that this
is like what you got to do or are you
doing it for uh dopamine detox thing or
are you doing it like in what context
just in general what do I think about it
yeah and what are the contexts in which
you think it's got some efficacy and
which are the ones that you think is pie
in the sky I think there are a lot of
people who are sedentary hermit that
basically never leave their house and
use Outlets like pornography to achieve
that dopamine hit that is otherwise a
lower barrier to entry way of achieving
that smashing the dopamine button is a
lot higher effort to go find a woman you
know go on a date with her uh you know
attract her get her into your bed you
know have sexual intercourse and
actually put energy expenditure into
that activity as well it's very easy to
sit at your computer that you're already
at open up the browser and smash the
dopamine button so a lot of people just
it's almost like uh weirdly
paralleled version of those rat studies
where they just wired their brands and
then give them the opportunity to smash
this this dopamine button essentially
and they always choose to smash it over
and over again
it's like that is very much paralleled I
think in a lot of
um men nowadays because it's just such a
ease of access now that there is nothing
to dissuade them from doing it and not
having the I don't know the willpower or
the even wants to try and avoid it to go
seek you know a higher quality of life
that might otherwise involve
companionship or whatever it is they
very much will take the easy route and
you know it still achieves the same
dopamine hit to them so for them it's
their there's wired to be you know for
them I think nofap could be useful
because at some point your biological
urges will be like get the [ __ ] out
there and have sex because you're
motivated so much just by frustration
yeah like the apathy and the complacency
that you have after busting a nut it's
just like you just don't really care
about anything you know
like why like why mightn't go find a
woman to be with when I'm satisfied and
I just feel fine you know I'm just
chilling here I don't need to do that so
that's where it would be useful yeah was
it not useful I think it's useful in
individuals who it has actually had a
detriment to their quality of life from
a relationship standpoint uh social
interaction standpoint some people end
up hindering the relationship quality
with their girlfriend too because
they're so porn addicted they end up you
know over masturbating and then exposing
themselves to stimuli that otherwise
makes them relatively unresponsive in an
actual real life setting with a woman
like there are many scenarios in which I
think nofap or more specifically no porn
potentially coupled with some degree of
nofap is worthwhile I think these get
conflated a lot is the nofap no porn
thing like a lot of people just say
nofap but in reality a lot of it is
problematic with the compounding effect
of the pornography exposure because if
you're just if you're just like thinking
about your girlfriend you bust a nut
because you haven't seen her in you know
a while I don't think that's bad
necessarily what else are you gonna do
you know so it's the pornography and
like tying that that the dopamine hit to
that activity that is overly problematic
and then the nofap if it gets if it's
excessive fapping or it's hindering your
drive to go do things in life that's
logical fapping yeah yeah like at that
point when you can actually sit down and
objectively look at yourself and say
this is impeding my ability to either
get high quality relationships maintain
them in some capacity or it's not
leading to what I feel to be a high
quality of life in general like at that
point I think think nofap is absolutely
worth trying I think there's definitely
a a lower ceiling for where it's
Justified to do no porn versus I think
no fap like not I don't necessarily
think nofap needs to even be in the same
conversation as no porn always which it
often is people just assume it to be one
in the same yeah it's kind of branding
no opponent's got a branding problem
because it's not as catchy yeah no fap's
quite catchy and I don't think even with
porn I don't think it has a zero place
like I think there are some scenarios in
which you know could be great maybe it
excites your sex life who knows it's
just a matter of like the exposure like
too much or too little too much of
something is always bad in general so as
you would expect at some point you are
crossing the threshold into impeding
your quality of life in some capacity
I've read about risks online of going
too long without coming for men
any truth to that at all it's uh there
was this one study I dug into it was
about
ejaculation frequency and there was a
pretty clear Trend whereby after a week
if you don't bust a nut you will have a
big spike in testosterone and then
thereafter you end up having this
plateau effect where it doesn't stay
high it kind of like dips back down and
then plateaus
at Baseline so I think there's some sort
of biological like Rhythm to trying to
drive you to do something and then it's
almost like with with fasting if people
fast the first few days you're super
hungry you have these biological urges
to go eat and get nutrients and then
your body sort of shifts into like a
anti-catabolic more like sustained just
preserve yourself hibernation mode and I
think that very much applies to
ejaculation and sexual activity too like
if you go too long without it your body
goes into a state of like seemingly
adjusting to no sexual activity to some
extent I am no longer a reproductive
being yeah like I am maybe I'm
ancestrally I am uh out on a hunt or I'm
lost somewhere or I'm at war or
something and I need to just not be too
concerned about this so with that if
that was the case and if this study was
to be believed and there's probably
other factors in blah blah but that
would suggest that around about a weekly
to uh fortnightly Cadence of either
having sex so fapping yeah would
actually be an advantage because I'm
going to guess you only get this Spike
once it's not like if you weren't to
bust a nut again for the remainder of
that month you're not going to get
weekly spikes each time you get one and
then it plateaus so yeah repeat the
cycle if you ejaculate that one weekend
then you reset the clock every time yeah
yeah yeah yeah but it's it again like I
don't necess this would be like a wild
biohack to try and just recommend and I
don't necessarily make sure you only
bust once a week not saying that yeah
it's just if you were somebody who was
to actually follow like what happens
biologically that seems to be in line
with what happens and a lot of people on
that do know fap they will also find
that it's extremely difficult at the
beginning and then after a while it's
like oh it's not that bad anymore and is
that maybe something that you actually
want to be adapted for yeah is actually
something that's so interesting like do
you want to be in a state of for example
Perpetual fasting where you just don't
desire nutrients like maybe maybe if
you're a bear who's hibernating like I
don't know but yeah well
um I was talking to Hamza who is kind of
my window into the younger guy's
personal development world and he was
saying that there's a lot of guys that
he knows who have attached their sense
of self-worth to the number of days
since they last fapped yeah there's
definitely something to be said about
the feeling like you're working towards
something and achieving something and
have power over your
your urges like you have a control over
your body because you definitely feel
like after you break a nofap streak
because you succumb to the urges you
feel like a piece of [ __ ] even though it
felt good for a second God damn it I
just I just [ __ ] up and the people who
are able to sustain and you know work
past that there's very much like a an
achievement of oh I've gone 27 days
without fapping or busting and I I'm you
know this is fantastic I have what's
Jerry Seinfeld say or uh George it's
like power over my domain or something
or I control my domain I forget what
they said but it's uh definitely
something to be said about the uh
um I don't know restraining definitely
giving guys a sense of reward for an
achievement of control of self not
giving in to urges like the same way you
would not give into you know craving
sugar or something and you feel good
about it I think some guys do would
expectedly tie their self-worth uh you
know I don't need sex I don't go I can
go this long without even feeling like I
need and it could sometimes extend into
a problematic thing where it's like I
don't even need a woman like [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] the other gender like I don't I
don't even need to have a companion
because I'm like that much of a lone
wolf who doesn't need to fap I don't
need a moment mode for the rest of my
life yeah yeah I think that is the um
goal-seeking mechanism kind of hijacked
by something because you can hijack it
with pretty much anything right you know
people I'm sure that serial killers get
a good amount of reward when they
finally find somebody and do what it is
they're going to do to them and dispose
of the body and maybe I'm going to get
caught and I don't you go well like
he's seeking a goal he's going after
something we wouldn't necessarily say
that it's something that's adaptive or
good for him to do the same thing goes
for the person that feels like they need
to use porn in order to satiate
themselves or like they get the reward
from that we can find goal seeking
behavior in pretty much anything it's
about planning in advance what that
behavior is going to be and do I
actually want to have this as something
which gets programmed in yeah
um
one of the concerns that's happening a
lot at the moment is around
um guys confidence with girls and you
know if you can get uh fake satisfaction
or a virtual satisfaction from the
comfort of your own home you know going
out and meeting women is like for a
nervous individual or someone that isn't
necessarily compelled to do it or
doesn't want to do it or whatever
um there is a get out of jail free card
there yeah the more dates side of your
channel was something that you spent a
good bit of time with
what did you learn about uh confidence
for guys around girls like if there was
someone that you were speaking to that
was a friend or whatever that was like
I'm just really super unconfident with
girls is there any interesting reframes
or insights that you relied on when you
were starting to build your confidence
where you think like that actually
helped like that was a really good
useful framing for me to think about
interacting with women
ah like for me it was more about
I was not happy with where I was at in
my life with the with my dating life and
lack of it entirely essentially so
typically guys who are underachieving in
some area if you I guess are wired a
certain way you may feel overly
motivated to compensate for that in some
way which could lead to you
almost overachieving that area to feel
like you've reached the Baseline that
somebody else who has just had it from I
don't know like a normal transition into
high school or whatever and had it you
know silver platter to them or something
because some guys they're just you know
we'll just get girls you know naturally
or they're naturally charismatic and
they don't have to like develop
whatsoever just turning off this alarm
for the Rogan comment
um
but yeah so for me it was more so like
can I foresee this as my life in the
future and am I satisfied with it and at
the time it was not something that I was
happy with and not something I felt like
oh in 10 years is this something that is
sustainable and that I feel
is something that I could ever be happy
with no it wasn't so I have to make a
change because this is just unacceptable
for me and at that point
I was just pushing myself massively out
of my comfort zone like it was not what
did that look like like literally going
around my campus in between classes and
just you know talking to girls that I
thought were attractive and just
striking up conversations essentially
and the reason for that is to overcome
approach anxiety fear yeah yeah so it
was uh and this was like before Tinder
and stuff really took off so there was a
very very like it was necessary to
actually talk to people in real life
still and maybe that's you know that has
shifted a little bit in recent times and
maybe it's more important to have like a
high level social media following and
you know Leverage The the DMS game and
stuff but
um I do think it's very important and
impactful on communication skills your
ability to articulate yourself the
ability to have high level even like
business presentations job interviews to
be able to if you can go up to a some
woman who you find attractive that's
sitting there that you've never met
before and just strike up a conversation
and have like a reasonable dialogue you
know get her number go on a date like
you could pretty much crush anything
that has to do with you know talking to
a bro or to a you know a potential
employer like oftentimes I find guys are
most scared of somebody they find that
they're trying to get something from
maybe or they otherwise are afraid of
rejection like admirable yeah I think
it's hard to it's hard to put into words
but if you can
oftentimes if you walk up to somebody
you deem to be extremely attractive and
you otherwise were terrified to talk to
you and that becomes like a a nothing
thing where you have no anxiety about it
and you can just smoothly on a whim walk
up to a girl and have a conversation and
introduce yourself and have a reasonable
dialogue
you can very much
throw yourself into a lot of social
situations that otherwise seemed
overwhelming prior how did you get over
the approach anxiety Beyond just it
being reps and this goes for girls as
well like girls also kind of need to get
over their own approach anxiety in a
post metoo world all of the dating
advice that they used to get which was
why men love [ __ ] and treat them like
you don't like him if girls roll forward
with that same like you know aloof Style
guys are going to take no as [ __ ] no not
uh maybe I need you to try a little bit
harder and be a bit more flirty with me
or something like that's the old world
and you know post 2010s they don't get
to do that anymore
was there anything that you relied on
like you're looking at the person that
you're gonna go and speak to and there's
a ringing in your ears and your heart
rate's at 120 and you're like sweating
what got you over the hill of being able
to begin doing that
um for me it was seeing people that I
found to be relatable
able to get over it themselves so I was
inspired by certain people that I saw
who had weren't happy with their lives
also be able to get over that and become
socially fluent have no anxiety walk up
on a whim to anybody they please Etc and
strike up what I feel to be high enough
level conversations that a woman is even
impressed or coming up to her
depending on the scenario because it
depends on you know if you're good
looking you're not creepy if you're not
good looking then you aren't like
there's a whole [ __ ] debate about
that whole thing where at the end of the
day all you can do is maximize your self
value through all of these different
vectors of gym lifestyle Etc But
ultimately the social components is very
controllable and something you can
develop and yeah it sort of is a reps on
reps thing unfortunately to some extent
and I think just jumping into the fire
or you know whatever saying you wanna
you know taking the plunge whatever it
often is just the necessary thing that
needs to be done to be able to develop
socially and I don't know if you need
somebody to hold your hand to do it I
don't necessarily know that
you you might be just giving yourself an
excuse like at the end of the day you're
not happy with your life so are you
going to change it or you're not like
you have to take some [ __ ] action at
the end of the day so for me it was very
motivating I saw a couple guys that were
capable of doing it and I suppose that
gave me a bit more inspiration than
maybe I would have otherwise had from
Baseline but at the end of the day I
didn't have somebody walk up with me to
the first girl I talked to I still had
to go up to her and say hi my name is
Derek what's yours I thought you were
cute I want to come talk to you Etc
whatever it was like once you get your
foot in the door and say something that
shows your intent very clearly you
introduce yourself you then put out the
premise that you know I'm interested in
you
are you open to you know a conversation
or not and you either succeed or you
don't and oftentimes you won't but
you'll never be able to figure out if it
was a successful thing or not if you
don't just try and talk to people and
that even goes to talking to dudes like
if you want to make a friend or whatever
or talk to a guy at the gym ask for a
spot like whatever it is like you have
to have some balls to be able to talk to
humans outside of in a online you know
gaming context or whatever I wonder
whether in the same way as porn has
given people a get out of jail free card
for uh faked signals of fitness and like
reproductive satisfaction if online
dating has done the same thing for
people not needing to develop
yeah like at the end of the day with
online dating you still have to meet up
with the girl and talk to her so you
could argue that it's just a more time
efficient way to do it and I'm not I'm
not debating that I think it is highly
useful the problem is with online dating
is you very much can't convey your
humor as well often or your tonality or
certain things that might otherwise set
you apart in person so I'm not saying
that you shouldn't rely on just online
dating because a lot of guys will just
crush it if they're have good enough
pictures and they have a good enough
profile but mostly pictures like they'll
crush it but a lot of guys won't like I
don't know if you've seen the statistics
on Tinder success rates of men versus
women it's like I don't know what it is
now it's probably like five percent of
men get 90 to 95 of the girls or
something and it's like well then what
do you do are you just [ __ ] do you
just do nothing like obviously you need
to if you want some level of I don't
know like a high quality relationship in
your life you have to take some action
in some capacity and I don't think the
excuses well it's just not going to
happen because Tinder didn't work out
like figure it out
dude I like it I really appreciate you
man thank you for coming and seeing me
what have you got coming up next is
there anything cool that people should
expect from you
um doing a pod with Zach calendar which
is gonna be cool you can do that right
after this
um I have a couple other podcasts coming
up that hopefully you guys will find
um interesting or useful in some
capacity they might vary and I don't
know how information dense they are or
like what the style is I'm trying to
like get out of my comfort zone a little
bit and do some more uh different styles
of podcasts that I haven't done before
so hopefully that is well received and
but in general you know you can find me
on YouTube or play with more dates or on
social media and any of those uh that
handle on any of the social media
platforms thanks man I appreciate you
right on you as well thanks man what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
face
[Music]